these last 14 years have gone by
so fast i have no regrets this was like
the best
decade and a half of my life it's the
end of an era as the kardashian jenner
say bye-bye
to keeping up with the kardashians after
20 seasons
oh my gosh such a gift the series
premiered on e on october 14
2007 and has followed the a-list family
through
all of their ups and downs it was a lot
of fun
keeping up even spawned 12 countum
12 spin-off series kim kardashian first
announced in september that the show
would be ending after
season 20. a decision that the show's
executive producer ryan seacrest
told et was not easy to make at some
point you're gonna say
you know we did it we had a great run
we're gonna live with a little more
privacy in our lives and i think they
just felt like
now is the time to do it and during the
series finale the family opened up about
keeping up's historic run
we've spent the last about 15 years
with most of our production members that
are with us
every single day in very intimate
situations and they're
my extended family it's really really
special in my opinion but it's
wild to just even
know how much i've gone through with all
of you guys by my side it's crazy
it was a good run it's the best job in
the world to be able to work with your
family every day
the family also marked the occasion with
a time capsule they buried in kim's yard
with each family member contributing a
sentimental item that reminded them of
their time on the show
kim put her first fragrance dashing in
the capsule
this is the first time that i've been i
remember that
on my own and it was so scary for me but
i did it and i fell in love with the
creative process
chloe shared the keys to the sisters
dash boutique which officially closed
all locations in 2018
as well as a hard drive full of video
interviews she conducted during the
family's final trip to tahoe
it's just so crazy how much i've gone
through
with all of you guys by my side getting
married
there's not all amazing things but
they're all life lessons i feel like
i've grown so much
we're having a baby just shows that if
you hold true to who you are
things will always get better similarly
courtney added a t-shirt from their
former children's boutique smooch
as a reminder of where she started i
feel so grateful
and like happy and you know
thankful that we've had such an amazing
job
and life and i just feel like we've all
grown
and learned and experienced so much
and so much that we wouldn't have
experienced without the show
kris jenner being the boss that she is
brought the certificate she framed after
trademarking the title momager
this is a period in my life that has
meant so much to me
when i think about season one to season
20 those are my most
magical memories no one knows what
tomorrow's going to bring but i have a
grateful heart as
for kendall and kylie the 25 year old
model added a painting of the family's
first house featured on the reality
series
and kylie added the first three lip kits
she ever launched as she kick-started
her beauty
we're empire in i'm having fun but my
personal favorite came courtesy of scott
disick
aka lord disick who added the regal cape
from when he was famously
and jokingly knighted during a family
trip to london
oh my god and on thursday the family
watched the finale
just like us and took to social media to
react to the emotional episode
it's such a beautiful thing chloe was
literally all of us
writing quote i need therapy after this
episode i
am sobbing and she followed it up with
is it normal to still be crying
yes yes it is coco i was like how am i
gonna get through this day
meanwhile chris responded to a fan who
asked how she was feeling about the show
coming to a close
tweeting it's such a mix of emotions i'm
so sad the show is ending
but feels so blessed for all the love
and support over the past 14 years
makes me proud courtney joked that she
missed out on morning because she was
busy talking during the episode
kendall admitted she's not good at
goodbyes and kylie retweeted ryan
seacrest's tweet about the show's ending
along with two white heart emojis as for
kim
she shared this clip from her final
moments of filming
and tweeted quote what a magical past 15
years it's been
all of the friendships we made and
things we've experienced
wow blessed blessed
you